didier laguerre bonjour aux auditrices
et auditeurs de matinée que la première
alors en tant que maire de fort de
france
quel a été votre préoccupation
prioritaire pour cette rentrée scolaire
et pour les 49 écoles les neuf crèches
publiques ce qui représente évidemment
des milliers d'enfants d'élèves kw à
6000 ses 100 élèves et 799 enfants dans
les crèches
ben c'est une grande surprise m'a plu
probation premier a été d'assurer la
sécurité face à l'épidémie de virus qui
nous qui nous frappent la suite la
sécurité des enfants des enseignants des
personnels municipaux et associatifs et
des parents et donc on a travaillé
pendant les vacances sur la base du
travail que nous avions menée
je me réjouis que nous ayons fait
l'effort d'ouvrir les écoles dès le
déconfinement et d'avant centre
d'accueil 10 enfants des soignants
pendant toute la période de confinement
aux crèches et en école ça nous a permis
d'avoir une bonne expérience pour
l'heure pour le personnel municipal
donc ça a été une expérience je dirais à
prenant en quelque sorte c'était pour
les uns et pour les autres
et qu'est ce que vous en avez tiré comme
principal enseignement appliqué pour
cette rentrée
ça nous a permis de tester les circuits
de dévolution des élèves dans les écoles
l'accès aux robinets de lavabo pour se
laver les mains voit que dans certains
établissements il fallait en mettre
d'autres
comment comment gérer les élèves dans
les cantines par exemple on est passé de
deux à trois services dans certaines
dans certaines écoles
il faut rajouter des tables et cm2 au
personnel de se préparer et depuis
depuis le dis je visite les écoles et le
personnel municipal me dit monsieur le
maire ou heureusement qu'on a fait ce
travail là à la fin du mois de mai oui
et justement il ya des agents
territoriaux des écoles et des crèches
aussi qui ont été formés ont enfin eu à
suivre des programmes de sensibilisation
justement c'est ce que vous expliquez à
la prise en charge des enfants est
attendue du protocole sanitaire
il est assez strict un autocollant nous
on applique si vous voulez un protocole
qui va au delà du protocole du nouveau
protocole sanitaire de l'éducation
nationale on essaie de rester le plus
près possible du protocole qu'on a
appliqué en mai au delà des delà de la
prise en main des enfants dans les
établissements on a fait des formations
avec nos agents sur la gestion de ces
situations là la prise en charge de
l'enfant qui pourrait être fiévreux par
exemple vous savez que dans les écoles
les enfants ils ont la grippe ils ont
détruit une maison toute espèce de
maladies avec des symptômes qui peuvent
rappeler le coup on a vu ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait comme on fait comment j'ai à
ce stress qui arrive dans
l'établissement et donc on a mis en
place des formations avec nous nous
agents pour ça pour qu'on soit le mieux
préparé possible
je ne dis pas qu'on ne peut pas avoir de
surprise mais qu'on soit le mieux
préparé possible que son capacité de
faire face à toute situation pour que la
sécurité de chacun soient jugés dans
l'école c'est ça qui est important mais
parce que malgré toutes ces préparations
le risque zéro n'existe pas donc est ce
qu'il vous reste justement de ce point
de vue tout de même quelques inquiétudes
ou ou interrogations globalement sur le
déroulement de ce début d'année scolaire
je pense notamment à la question des
transports n'ont pas d'inquiétude
particulière en un an nahl des écoles en
a beaucoup d'écoles à fort de france 49
écoles pour six mille cinq cents élèves
avec une moyenne de 2 entre 18 et 19
élèves par classe parce qu on a beaucoup
d'écoles dans les 46 ne connais pas très
fortement impliqué concernés et impactés
par la pole et matic transport car
rapport par rapport aux écoles et
heureusement d'ailleurs puisque on a de
vrais problèmes de transports collectifs
actuellement sur le territoire de la
cacem et en particulier un fonds de
france 2 par contre alors dans les
transports y compris lens profite du
covoiturage que si la dépose enfants
sylla etc se pose la question du risque
de
de contamination est donc le père l
impérieux respect du port du masque dans
l'est dans les transports collectifs et
dans la rue aussi tout simplement parce
que dans ce coin à distance un peu
réduite quoi alors justement il ya
quelques modalités pratiques qui sont
pas peut-être évidente pour les parents
je pense notamment au fait que les
parents ne sont pas autorisés à entrer
dans les bâtiments c'est ce alors qu'est
ce que cela signifie exactement c'est à
dire dans l'école même il faut qu'il
reste ça signifie qu'ils peuvent plus
entrer ils peuvent plus pénétrer même
temps dans l'école ça dépend des écoles
ça dépend de l'organisation par exemple
à la rentrée certaines écoles ont permis
aux parents donc ils ont organisé des
rentes riche le neo permet aux parents
de rentrer dans la cour ça nous a
obligés à revoir les protocoles
d'accueil des parents de travailler
aussi avec les associations qui prennent
en charge la la garderie l'objectif
étant d'éviter qu'on on est comme ça se
faisait avant un groupe de parents et
d'enfants qui sont très proches les uns
des autres autour de la ponte attendant
que les enfants sortent ou attendant de
pouvoir anti conduit si on peut gérer
les distances physiques entre les
parents et les enfants au moment où de
l'arrivée ou du départ des enfants et 6
acquis qui est intéressant dans
l'expérience qu'elle était menée au mois
de mai alors comment ça se présente
concernant les moyens matériels
d'hygiène l'élégant les masques de
protection d'autres chaînes comment ils
toutes les écoles sont équipées de 2,2
points d'eau pour permettre aux enfants
de se laver les mains de papier pour
s'essuyer les mains de savons aussi
pause puisque il faut se laver les mains
plutôt que du texas est la ville qui
fournit la ville fournit normalement est
traditionnellement et en plus on a
rajouté dans nos écoles du gel
hydroalcoolique permettant de faire face
à une situation particulière et puis
tous nos agents sont équipés de masques
chirurgicaux de masques jetables ce qui
leur permet de se de se protéger et nous
avons des masques et des thermomètres
aussi que nous mettons dans les écoles
pour pouvoir prendre la température en
cas de difficultés en a identifié nos
chaque école un lieu où on pourrait par
exemple
confiné monsieur carouge qui serait
suspect de du virus de façon qui soit ce
qu'ils soient pris en charge et qu'ils
ne contaminent pas pendant qu'on attend
qu'on vienne nous comme en charge
l'ensemble des enfants de la classe ou
dut ou de l'école mais à côté de ça vous
vous j'étais dans une écolière vous
voyez les enfants qui font tout ce qui
est à faire et ensuite quand il part
dans leur classe historienne par la main
donc il ya aussi un travail à faire avec
les enfants pour qu'ils changent de
tactique et ça c'est ce sera peut-être
probablement le travail le plus long ça
se fait pas du jour au lendemain et
évidemment les masques pour les pour les
élèves pour les enfants ce sont les
parents en france aussi mais les masques
sont demandés à partir de 11 ans donc
les à partir de à partir
le maire de fort de france a pris la
décision d'offrir au personnel municipal
des masques pour leurs enfants de plus
de 11 ans de façon à ce qu'ils puissent
être équipés
et puis on distribue des masques ou aux
personnes vulnérables dans dans les
quartiers à la fois des masques que la
ville a commandé puis des masses que
nous avons reçus de l'étape ce que
l'état donné une dotation de 50 qu'il
masque pour la martinique ont 2000 près
de 13000 masque profond de france que
nous distribuons dans les quartiers il
sent le fait depuis depuis plusieurs
semaines du confinement
alors encore une question concernant
cette pensée l'actualité c'est rentrée
scolaire vous avez fait le choix du
maintien de la garderie du matin et du
soir
vous confirmez oui oui t'as vu
périscolaire enfin ont fait un accueil
de fonctionner l'école normalement donc
on a la garde
d'autres villes soit qu'ils ont fait où
on a des centres de loisirs l'école les
centres aérés comment les appeler à
l'époque c'est un seul organisé par la
ville le mercredi et certains organisés
par des associations dans l'est pour les
courtes vacances aussi pour les nous on
a fait ce qu'on a fait mais comment
ferez vous alors que d'autres villes ont
fait s'ils refusent ont fait d'autres
choix
certains pourraient se demander si c'est
bien raisonnable de le faire d'une part
globalement et puis budgétairement aussi
est-ce que c'est un budget déjà des
surcoûts et son fils à la condition
qu'on va qu'on va convaincre il faut
l'argent ne fait pas tout mais pourquoi
pourquoi avez vous fait ce choix de
danse de maintenir parce que les
individus
l'éducation c'est une transmission de
savoirs pédagogique d'accord mais c'est
aussi tout ce qui va autour la prise en
charge des enfants avant la classe après
la classe entre midi et deux le mercredi
parce que les parents qui travaillent
ont des problématiques de garde de leurs
enfants et donc dire ok ça va me coûter
de l'argent
quelques milliers d'euros de plus parce
qu'il faut que je mette du gel du mas du
savon etc
donc je ne fais pas je repense coup sûr
le parent parlons qui lui même est
souvent confrontés à des situations
économique compliquée par rapport à
justement la crise économique et la
crise sociale convient donc pour moi
j'ai fait le choix de maintenir ces
accueils de loisirs et je rappelle que
pendant la période de confinement et je
veux remercier l'association qui a
travaillé avec nous on a accueilli des
enfants de soignants dans des écoles et
crèches mais on a aussi mis en place ces
centres de loisirs pour que justement
après la prise en charge par les
enseignants les enfants puissent être
être pris en charge et accompagner et
jusque on l'avait 9 calais jusqu'au
dimanche de façon à ce que les soignants
puisse exercer en toute tranquillité
donc on a cette expérience là qui nous
permet de continuer à mettre en place
nos centres de loisirs et finalement de
faire en somme elle est donc vous avez
les moyens financiers budget qui devrait
si je vous répète ici pas un c'est pas
un problème c'est d'abord une question
de volonté et une question de faire en
sorte que malgré l'épidémie
ben la vie suivre son cours tout
simplement didier laguerre le maire de
fort de france et dans 16 autres cas dit
alors on va changer de sujet pour
terminer des réponses pas trop longue si
vous faites
c'est l'actualité aussi quelques
nouvelles de la commission municipale
mémoire et transmission didier laguerre
après les troupes de ces dernières
semaines des quelques statues renversées
ici ou là alors quelle sera sa première
où ses premières actions concrètes à
cette commission mémoire et transmet ses
premières actions concrètes ont déjà été
de faire la proposition de la dépose de
la statue de jean luc qui devait passer
en conseil municipal le 28 juillet
d'entre vous ont devancé d'autres n'ont
pas n'ont pas souhaité attendre que les
choses se fassent
selon le rythme municipal de proposer
des noms de rue a débaptisé mais surtout
faire des propositions pour remplacer le
nom de la rue propositions qui font
l'objet de débats
actuellement c'est la commission et qui
feront et on verra des résultats assez
rapidement c'est une commission le 10
septembre prochaine commission convoqué
le 10 septembre avec un ordre du jour
que j'ai vu et qui comprend par exemple
le retour de l'étude sur la place des
femmes et des noms des femmes dans les
rues de dans l'espace public faut y
aller par exemple des propositions de
deux nouveaux noms pour certaines rues
de fort-de-france gallieni blayac et ses
innovations déjà un petit peu ciblé vous
savez quelle ruse j'avais déjà deux
mériterait quand j'ai fait changer une
émission dans mon programme
j'avais déjà un système de wiki posait
problème gallieni blayac et c'est donc
j'ai demandé à la commission de travail
et de commencer par travailler pas parce
qu il est donc elle se réunit le 10
septembre nous fera sont des
propositions et ensuite nous les
mettrons au débat public elle doit
organiser des forums dans les quartiers
etc
les mettrons débat public éventuellement
nous ferons une consultation municipal
enfin populaire vous pensez didier
laguerre que ce nature assez de nature à
rasséréner un peu le débat je souhaite
une loi de nature à instaurer le
dialogue a attisé le débat et surtout à
nous permettre d'avancer sur la place de
notre histoire et la représentation de
notre soi et de nos symboles dans notre
espace public
allez on va terminer avec la une
actualité à venir quelques superbes
perspectives bientôt oui bientôt il y
aura les élections territoriales très
bientôt c'est dans six mois c'est après
demain
oui vous y pensez
non pas plus que ça je les dis pendant
la campagne je les dis je me consacre
exclusivement à ma fonction de maire et
de vice président de la cacem je
considère que c'est largement suffisant
alors le maire de l'accord la vie mais
le militant et le responsable politique
le pdg le responsable politique du ppm
pense qu'il est fondamental que nous
changions la gouvernance de la
collectivité territoriale et martinique
de façon à ce que la martinique euro
prenne sa place dans dans l'espace
français et que la martinie gros comment
ça a évolué et a avancé on avoue des
dossiers qui seront serait pas vous ne
serez pas sur une liste mais vous vous
avez vous senti comme un challenge à
chaque campagne électorale je suis
militant je suis autonomiste je défends
des convictions politiques
je défends une vision du développement
de la martinique est donc je prendrai
pas part aux débats publics se préparent
ce rendez vous évidemment évidemment
comme tous les partis vous avez déjà
déterminé qu'ils ont sur la liste non
n'a pas encore ouvert notre procédure
démocratique de désignation des
candidats mais j'ose dire que ça ne se
ne saurait trop tarder mais nous
travaillons à la construction d'un
projet de développement pour la
martinique perm que nous soumettrons
martiniquais vont permettre à ce pays de
de se projeter dans l'avenir et d'offrir
des perspectives assez jeune tout
simplement
didier laguerre merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
voilà merci à tous bonne vous vous
retrouvez jimmy